THE COMMITTEE IS EXPECTED TO
ANNOUNCE REFERRALS TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP, FOR
INCITING VIOLENCE AT THE CAPITOL
THAT DAY.
LET'S LOOK BACK AT SOME OF THE
BIGGEST MOMENTS FROM THE
HEARINGS.
>> NOT ONLY DID PRESIDENT TRUMP
REFUSE TO TELL THE MOB TO LEAVE
THE CAPITOL, HE PLACED NO CALL
TO ANY ELEMENT OF THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT TO INSTRUCT
THAT THE CAPITOL BE DEFENDED.
>> WHAT MADE YOU DECIDE TO
LEAVE?
>> BASICALLY WHEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP PUT HIS TWEET OUT, WE
LITERALLY LEFT RIGHT AFTER THAT
COME OUT.
>> AFTER OUR LAST HEARING,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO CALL A
WITNESS IN OUR INVESTIGATION.
>> THE PRESIDENT REACHED UP
TOWARDS THE FRONT OF THE VEHICLE
TO GRAB AT THE STEERING WHEEL.
MR.
MR. ENGEL GRABBED HIS ARM SAID,
SIR, YOU NEED TO TAKE YOUR ARM
OFF THE STEERING WHEEL.
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE WEST
WING.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO THE CAPITOL.
MR. TRUMP USED HIS FREE HAND TO
LUNGE TOWARDS BOBBY ENGEL THEN.
>> WHAT I SAW WAS SOMETHING OUT
OF A WAR SCENE, SOMETHING I HAD
SEEN OUT OF THE MOVIES.
I CAN'T BELIEVE MY EYES.
>> I AFFECT MY LIFE IN A MAJOR
WAY.
IN EVERY WAY.
ALL BECAUSE OF LIES.
>> I THOUGHT THAT THE TWEET
ABOUT THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS THE
LAST THING THAT WAS NEEDED IN
THAT MOMENT.
IT WAS ESSENTIALLY HIM GIVING
THE GREEN LIGHT TO THESE PEOPLE,
TELLING THEM THAT WHAT THEY WERE
DOING AT THE STEPS OF THE
CAPITOL AND ENTERING THE CAPITOL
WAS OKAY, THAT THEY WERE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IN THEIR ANGER.
AND HE SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN DOING
THAT.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN TELLING
THESE PEOPLE TO GO HOME AND TO
LEAVE.
>> SO, LET'S BRING IN THE PERSON
YOU JUST HEARD FROM THERE,
FORMER DEPUTY WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY UNDER FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP, SARAH MATTHEWS.
WHO RESIGNED THE NIGHT OF THE
RIOTS AND TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE.
YOU TESTIFIED YOU WERE ONE OF
THE FEW PEOPLE WHO WENT OUT AND
DID IT.
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE SUPERIOR
TO YOU IN THE ADMINISTRATION
FOUGHT APPEARING BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE, INCLUDING THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT.
I WONDER AS WE REFLECT ON THEIR
WORK SO FAR IF YOU THINK JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE HAS ACCOMPLISHED
WHAT THEY SET OUT TO ACCOMPLISH?
>> I THINK THEY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR GOAL.
I THINK THEY WANTED TO SHED
LIGHT ON WHAT REALLY HAPPENED,
HOW COULD SOMETHING LIKE JANUARY
6th HAPPEN HERE IN AMERICA.
AND WHAT THEY UNCOVERED IS THAT
THIS WAS A VERY ORCHESTRATED
PLOT BY PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
CONSPIRATORS.
I WAS INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
MYSELF AND I DIDN'T REALIZE THIS
WAS GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES,
THE FULL EXTENT OF IT.
I WAS LEARNING IN REAL-TIME WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WATCHING IT
UNFOLD IN THE HEARINGS.
I THINK THE HEARINGS WERE
COMPELLING AND PROVIDED A LOT OF
EVIDENCE TO SHOW THAT TRUMP
TRIED TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION
AND DID NOT ACT ON JANUARY 6th
TO DO ANYTHING WHEN A MOB THAT
HE INCITED STORMED THE CAPITOL.
>> WE'RE EXPECTING CRIMINAL
REFERRALS THAT ARE COMING, AS
DON WAS SAYING EARLIER, THEY
HAVE IMPACT BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
TEETH ESSENTIALLY.
IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY REQUIRE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO ACT.
I WONDER, AS YOU'VE SEEN ALL OF
THIS PUT TOGETHER, YOU WERE
THERE ON JANUARY 6th INSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WILL YOU BE DISAPPOINTED IF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DOESN'T
PURSUE THAT ROUTE?
>> I WILL BE DISAPPOINTED.
I THINK THAT NO ONE IS ABOVE THE
LAW AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE, PRESIDENT
TRUMP INCLUDED.
AND I THINK THAT THE -- IT WILL
BE CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT DOJ HAS
IN TERMS OF EVIDENCE COMPARED TO
WHAT THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
HAS.
AND THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE IS
PLANNING TO MAKE ALL OF THEIR
EVIDENCE PUBLIC FROM WHAT I'VE
HEARD.
SO THAT'S GREAT.
AND THAT COULD HELP POTENTIALLY
DOJ WITH THEIR INVESTIGATION.
BUT IT DOES SEEM DOJ IS
FOLLOWING A SIMILAR ROUTE RIGHT
NOW TO WHAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
PURSUED IN TERMS OF WITNESSES
THEY BROUGHT IN AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE.
SO I HOPE THAT'S THE CASE SO
THEY'LL PURSUE THAT ROUTE.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING
TO GO BACK TO SOMETHING YOU
SAID.
YOU SAID YOU WERE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE WHEN IT HAPPENED.
>> UM-HUM.
>> AND YOU FOUND OUT IN REAL
TIME WHAT WAS HAPPENING ALONG
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE YET YOU
WERE THERE.
WHAT IS THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN THE WEST
WING AND HAPPENING WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND THE ADMINISTRATION
AND QUITE FRANKLY MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BECAUSE I FOUND IT
FASCINATING THAT PEOPLE WEREN'T
SCREAMING AT THE TOP OF THEIR
LUNGS STOP THIS.
IT SEEMED LIKE EVERYONE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
>> YEAH, I WAS A COUPLE LAYERS
REMOVED BEING A DEPUTY PRESS
SECRETARY, I WASN'T IN THE
MEETINGS PRIVY TO SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT PEOPLE THAT
WERE MORE SENIOR TO ME WOULD
HAVE BEEN --
>> WAS THERE AN EFFORT TO
SUPPRESS IT OR IT JUST HAPPENED
THAT WAY?
>> I THINK THERE WAS AN EFFORT
TO SUPPRESS IT.
I THINK PEOPLE ON THE CAMPAIGN
SIDE AS WELL WERE TRYING TO TELL
THE PRESIDENT, HEY, YOU KNOW
WHAT, THERE'S NO EVIDENCE HERE,
ONCE ALL HIS LITIGATION FAILED
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE TO OVERTURN
THE RESULTS OF THE ELECTION.
AND THAT'S WHEN YOU STARTED TO
SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT LISTEN
TO THOSE FOLKS ANYMORE AND THEN
START TO LISTEN MORE TO THE
PEOPLE FEEDING HIM CONSPIRACIES
AND LIES AND IT SEEMS HE'S
CONVINCED HIMSELF OF THOSE LIES.
>> IN THIS TIME SINCE JANUARY
6th, WHAT I WAS STRUCK BY THAT
DAY IS SPEAKING WITH PEOPLE,
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, PEOPLE WERE SO FREAKED
OUT BY WHAT HAPPENED THAT DAY, A
LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE YOU WERE SO
UPSET BY WHAT HAPPENED, NOT ALL
OF THEM RESIGNED.
I WONDER WHAT YOU MAKE OF HOW
YOU SAW YOUR COLLEAGUES REACT TO
THAT DAY VERSUS TODAY, HOW THEY
TRY TO DOWN PLAY THE COMMITTEE
GIVEN IT IS COMING TO AN END?
>> I THINK THAT DAY, MY
COLLEAGUES INSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE AND, YOU KNOW, REPUBLICANS
THAT I'M FRIENDS WITH ON CAPITOL
HILL, EVERYONE ACROSS THE BOARD
WAS EQUALLY DISTURBED.
IT WAS ONE OF THE DARKEST DAYS I
THINK IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY.
BUT I DO THINK IT'S STRANGE HOW
NOW SOME PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, WHO
WERE A COUPLE YEARS REMOVED FROM
IT, SEEM TO HAVE SHORT MEMORIES
AND NOT REALIZE HOW BIG OF A
DEAL THAT DAY WAS.
AND I THINK A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
WOULD RATHER MOVE ON FROM IT,
WHITEWASH OVER THE EVENTS OF
THAT DAY FOR POLITICAL
EXPEDIENCY.
WHICH IS DISAPPOINTING BECAUSE I
THINK, LIKE I SAID EARLIER, NO
ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW, DONALD
TRUMP NEEDS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND SO DO HIS
CO-CONSPIRE OR THES.
>> THANKS FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
WE HAVE A LOT TO COVER TODAY.
THANKS FOR SHARING YOUR INSIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.